The prequels I thought were almost an
impossible task how do you tell this
story that we've all grown up with
imagining who Anakin Skywalker was in
Phantom Menace you're watching these two
Jedi in their prime fight this evil
villain Maul couldn't be more obviously
the villain he's designed to look
evil and he is evil and he just
expressed that from his face all the way
out to the type of lightsaber he
fights with. What's at stake is really
how Anakin is gonna turn out because
qui-gon is different than the rest of
the Jedi and you get that in the movie
and qui-gon is fighting because he knows
he's the father that Anakin needs
because qui-gon hasn't given up on the
fact that Jedi are supposed to actually
care and love and that that's not a bad
thing the rest of the Jedi are so
detached and they've become so political
that they've really lost their way and
Yoda starts to see that in the second
film but qui-gon is ahead of them all
and that's why he's not part of the
council so he's fighting for Anakin and
that's why it's the duel of the fates
the fate of this child and depending on
how this fight goes Anakin is gonna. His
life is gonna be dramatically different
so qui-gon loses of course and he's left
with obi-wan obi-wan trains Anakin at
first out of a promise he makes to
qui-gon not because he cares about him
when they get Anakin they find him on
Tatooine he says why do I feel like we
found another useless life-form he's
comparing Anakin to Jar Jar excuse me
and he's saying this is a waste of our
time why are we doing this why do you
see importance in these creatures like
Jar Jar Binks in this ten-year-old boy
this is useless so he's a brother to
Anakin eventually but he's not a father
figure that's a failing for
Anakin he doesn't have the the family
that he needs he loses his mother in the
next film he fails on this promise that
he made his mother. I will come back and save
you so he's left completely vulnerable
and Star Wars ultimately is about family
so that moment in that movie which a lot
of people I think diminishes it's all
just a cool lightsaber fight but it's
it's everything that the entire three
films of the prequels hangs on is that
one particular fight and Maul serves his
purpose and at that point died before
George made me bring him back but he died
and that's it showing you again how the
Emperor is completely self-serving he
doesn't care it's just a tool that he's
using people and I was gonna use this
child
that follows all the way through to the
line which terrified me as a kid when
the emperor tells Luke you like your
father are now mine.
Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is going to  be my
new Mandalorian video for dave felonies
duel of the fates clip and why it's so
important to the Star Wars franchise but
also how his conversation is important
for what's going on with the Mandalorian
in the baby Yoda character during its
overarching story so all this stuff that
they're doing here in this clip this is
all for the Mandalorian series we also
found out about another really huge
Clone Wars character that's going to debut
live action during the mandalorian
season too so I'll talk about that
during the video as well if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing a Disney
Plus giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Mandalorian moment on the video
careful for spoilers for everything that
happened during season one and we'll
just do this top 5 style starting with
number 5 so Dave Filoni they're just
dropping some hot knowledge on the
importance of the Phantom Menace and the
duel of the fates fight scene how it's
so important for setting up the entire
Skywalker saga the importance of qui-gon
jinn the failure of obi-wan Kenobi not
being able to be the father figure to
young Anakin Skywalker that he needed to
be because the duel of the fates is
literally them dueling over the fate of
this child Anakin Skywalker that the
emperor is going to use whatever your
feelings on the prequels were I feel
like Dave Filoni just made Phantom
Menace that much cooler as a movie like
you find out new information new context
and it suddenly makes the movie way
cooler than you originally thought it
was he also talks about the overarching
theme that the emperor was responsible
for controlling Anakin using him as a
tool just like Darth Maul forcing him to
do all these evil things and now he's
getting ready to do it too Luke
Skywalker in Return of the Jedi that
line of dialogue where the Emperor is
basically telling Luke you're mine now
take your father's place and despite the
fact that Luke hasn't done anything that
you could call evil he's got this
darkness to him at times in Fulani truly
believes that Luke would have gone to
the dark side but number 4 the thing
that saved him from succumbing to his
hatred like the Emperor wanted is Luke
looking at Darth Vader his father the
Emperor his cybernetic hand then his
lightsaber taking it all into context
saying I'm going to be selfless throwing
the lightsaber away so it's not his
great Jedi POW
this save Luke Skywalker in that moment
or save Darth Vader it's Luke's love of
his father so as he says the son saves
the father then the father saves the son
and and he says you know I am a Jedi
like my father before me but he's really
saying and why we connect I connect so
powerfully to is like he's saying I love
my father and there's nothing you can do
that's gonna change that and the
emperor can't understand that connection
why wouldn't you take this, I'm offering
you power of the galaxy and Anakin then
in that moment has to decide to be the
father that he's never had he has to
give up all the power of the galaxy and
save his son and that's what saves him
in terms, so the Son Saves the father and
father saves his son and it works out
perfectly and I draw that line all the
way from Phantom Menace to Jedi that's
the story of Star Wars.
I'll explain how this is all important to
the story of
baby Yoda in the Mandalorian in a second
to remember the whole reason why Dave
Filoni was laying all that knowledge on
the duel of the fates on everyone in
that room for the Mandalorian is because
they're talking about the Mandalorian
series and if you're wondering where all
these cool clips are coming from this is
actually from the Mandalorian a special
series that they're doing on Disney Plus
it's sort of a documentary series for
the Mandalorian there are eight episodes
total they're airing episodes weekly
this clip that I was talking about was
from Episode two I will do more videos
for the series but because it's kind of
a documentary it doesn't really lend
itself to the top 10 episode videos
that I would normally do so we'll try to
find some other way to do videos for
this special Mandalorian series so 3 why
is this important - baby Yoda in the
Mandalorians story well it's already
implied that Moff Gideon wants to use
baby yoda as part of a secret cloning
project for some new force sensitive
darkside troopers but it also sounds
like he wants to use baby yoda himself
as a tool the way that the Emperor used
Darth Vader and then tried to use Luke
Skywalker and based on what Dave Filoni
is saying about how Luke Skywalker saved
his father Anakin Skywalker than Anakin
save Luke what will ultimately save baby
Yoda from succumbing to the dark side
like Luke Skywalker will be his
relationship with Mandalorian his father
figure so the son baby Yoda winds up
saving the father the Mandalorian and
then the father
Mandalorian winds up saving the son
that's why it's so important that grief
carga had that line of dialogue
basically saying that exactly
at the end of season 1 episode 8 he says
something like you'll save him then
maybe he'll also save you take care of
this
or maybe it'll take care of you number
two we've already seen baby Yoda has a
darkness in him too like Luke Skywalker
had a darkness in him he was totally
willing to force choke Cara dune that's
a technique favored by the Sith but it's
still so early in the Mandalorian series
that a lot of these larger Luke
Skywalker Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader
Emperor themes probably won't totally be
paid off until the final season whatever
that winds up being either season five
or season six or whatever they decide to
end the series so it's always awesome to
watch Dave Filoni show how much he
understands Star Wars and how much he
cares about it I know a lot of you have
asked if he would ever take a bigger
leadership role over the Star Wars brand
at Lucasfilm what's happening right now
is that he's actually sort of getting
his feet wet in live action with the
Mandalorian series I think that
eventually what will happen is is he'll
get a chance to direct a live-action
Star Wars movie then eventually if that
goes well then he will probably
eventually take over the Star Wars brand
but number one really awesome news
welcome to the Mandalorian lady Bo Katan
there was a report this morning that
Katee Sackhoff has been cast as Bo Katan
for the mandalorian season two live
action Bo Katan most of you know her is
the voice of animated Bo Katan and the
Clone Wars or during Star Wars rebels
later in the timeline my biggest theory
about her character during season two is
that it's going to be connected to
Mandalorian Great Purge flashbacks of
some kind or around that period and
it'll be connected to the backstory on
the darksaber and how Moff Gideon got
it in baby Yoda's backstory if you
didn't watch the Clone Wars you don't
know who Bo Katan is or why it's a big
deal that they're doing her live-action
she's actually the younger sister of
duchess Satine Kryzeformer ruler of
Mandalore and the only woman that
obi-wan Kenobi ever loved her younger
sister Katee Sackhoff's characer Bo Katan
was also a part of the Death Watch
Mandalorians at one point under pre
vizla former wielder of the darksaber
voiced by Jon Favreau remember he also
did the voice of the heavy infantryman
Mandalorian during season one who was
part of house Vizsla somov Gideon had to
have gotten the darksaber from Bo Katan
at some point during the Great Purge
either because he killed her or he stole
it from her she was the last person to
have it right before the start of a new
hope so my first big theory is that her
story during season two is just can
mostly to that stuff it's totally
possible that she's alive in present-day
and we'll see her help Mandalorian and
baby Yoda somehow along with ahsoka tano
who also has a deep connection to Bogut
and via the Clone Wars in the siege of
Mandalore we just saw that play out
during the final four episodes of the
Clone Wars which were amazing so if you
haven't watched those new episodes at
least watched the last four episodes of
the Clone Wars they overlap with Revenge
of the Sith and they make the movie so
much better Bogut and herself was the
last major leader of the Mandalorian
people right before a new hope before
the great purge so she's a core part of
the Mandalorians personal history around
the time that he took his oath as a
Mandalorian when he was younger but if
we get any other news about what's going
on with season 2 guest stars or Clone
Wars characters coming to live action
like Rex I will totally do a video about
it post all your predictions in the
comments below and everyone click here
for my Mandalorian season 2 Boba Fett
teaser video and click here for my Clone
Wars season 7 finale video thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe
This is the way!